Normally, when we think about routing of packets on
the internet, typically what happens is. At the source
node, you create a network packet and go through
the layers of software stack on the sending node, and
send the packet out on the network. And this
network packet has a desired destination. And of course,
it has to go through a whole number of
intermediate routers in order to get to its eventual destination.
And the routers on the Internet that are intermediate between
the source and the destination, they don't inspect the packet for
the contents or anything like that. All that they're doing is
when the packet comes in, they're looking at the destination known
for that packet and figuring out what is the next
hub that I have to send the packet to. So each
router is making the determination of the next hub for the
package, and it makes the determination by doing a table lookup.
So every router has a routing table, and the
routing table is telling. Given a particular destination, what
is the next hop? And that's how the packet
flows from source to destination through a whole bunch of
intermediate routers and finally gets to the destination. So
in other words, the routers en route to the destination
from the source, are simply forwarding packets. That is,
the nodes are passive. And they're just doing a table
lookup in order to figure out what is the
next hop that I have to send this packet
to? Now, what does it mean to make the
nodes active? What we mean by making the node
active is that the next hop for sending this
package towards a destination is not simply a table
look up. But it is actually determined by the
router executing code that is actively as opposed to doing
just a passive table look up. So, in other
words, the packet in addition to the payload that
is intended for the destination also carries code with
it. And the code is being executed by the
router in order to make a determination as to
what to do with this packet in terms of
routing it towards the desired destination. This sounds really
clever because it can provide customized service for networks
flows that are going through the network. And every
network can have its own way of choosing what
may be the desired route, in terms of going
from source to destination. And so in other words
we're saying. Well, this is an opportunity to virtualize
the traffic flow from my network traffic independent of
other network flows. This should be very familiar to
you all because we've been talking about customizing operating
system services in the SPIN operating system, and
the XO kernel and so on. But, of
course, the problem that we're talking about here,
much, much, harder because the network is wide open.
Our network traffic flow is going through the
public internet infrastructure ,and we are talking about
specializing the network flow for every network flow
independent of others. There are lots of challenges to
this values of active network. In particular, how can we
write such code that we can distribute and send it
over the wire so that routers can execute it. And
who can write such code? And how can we be sure
that the injected code does not break the network? Or
in other words, for a particular network flow, there is
a code that is going to be centered on. How do
we make sure that is not going to in some way [UNKNOWN]
other network flows? These are things that we
have to worry about and sort of opening up
the router and saying that we're going to take
network flow specific decisions in each of the routers.